Greetings all.
Very good.
There are, at the moment, 66 people, all looking at me, for heaven's sake.
That's very lovely.
So, I'll just start in my usual way.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
I'm presuming you can hear me.
It's always good to have a little test there.
If somebody could just give me a nod to say they can hear me, that would lessen my sense of overwhelming anxiety.
Nobody's answering.
Well, I'm just presuming you can hear me.
Yes, I'll have to presume.
So I hope you had a fruitful day.
Very good.
Loud and clear.
Thank you so much.
Very good.
Audio is great.
Right.
I'm with it.
Yeah, that's enough.
Thank you very much.
So, yes, hopefully you've had a fruitful day.
Just to reiterate, if you want to have, if something comes up which is a bit heavy for you to handle, feel free to get in touch.
Use my email, bbbodhibodhi at gmail.com.
Sometimes it's good just to talk to somebody.
I'm thinking, obviously, especially for those people who find themselves locked in by themselves, that can be a bit of a miserable state.
although these days it's lessened with um all the social media that's a blessing really so i'm just making sure i'm actually
Yeah, sorry, I wasn't plugged in properly.
Gotta get used to all this stuff, you know?
So I just wanted to, oh, by the way, the little talk I give in the evenings, you'll find them as separate little items on the channel so that if you happen to miss some of my pearls of wisdom one night, you can always check it up
in the daytime okay so i wanted to answer these questions that were sent to me to what extent can it be argued that the four noble truths was the most was the buddha's most important teaching it sounds a bit like one of these a-level questions and uh are all the stages of the eightfold path equally important uh now
this uh discourse which is the uh samaditi the right uh the right view discourse where sariputta is being asked basically um what um what do we need to understand what right view do we need to have in order to become uh liberated and he gives various uh various uh answers to that
And there's a sort of suggestion that if you understand any of these fully, that would lead to liberation.
Now, that only makes sense when we realize that the teaching, the Dharma, is all one piece, really.
Once you investigate one part of it, it naturally leads you to other parts.
Anyway, he's being asked again, but friend, might there be another way?
which a noble disciple is of right view and has arrived at this true dharma and he says yes there is and then there is what you might call a regular expression of the four noble truths so i'll read those out what is the noble truth of suffering what is the origin of suffering what is the cessation of suffering and what is the way leading to the cessation of suffering so there's your four noble truths
birth is suffering aging is suffering sickness is suffering death is suffering sorrow lamentation pain grief and despair are suffering not to obtain what one wants is suffering in short the five aggregates of effect of clinging are suffering okay so we'll take it one by one yeah uh now
that's pretty straight that's pretty straightforward isn't it i mean the whole business of being born is not particularly pleasant either for the for the child and the mother and then aging and all so all of it is pretty straightforward but then there's this uh little uh little sentence not obtaining what one wants now there's your there's there's your frustration your anxiety that you might not get it all that sort of stuff now this word
Dukkha, that's what it's translating, suffering.
These days, people prefer unsatisfactoriness.
The word dukkha itself means just hard to bear.
Du is like, it just means bad, not good.
And ka means to bear something.
So it's something that's difficult to bear.
And it's used figuratively, for instance, to describe an axle in a wheel, which doesn't quite fit.
So you get the grinding noise, it doesn't quite fit.
And what Dukkha, what the Buddha is saying, the way he's using the word, is not just on these obvious things like, you know, ordinary sufferings and pains and all that sort of stuff.
But there is this business of not getting what one wants.
and uh and that's to do with you know our desires our expectations so that obviously causes us a lot of suffering but the next sentence goes a little deeper it says the five aggregates affected by clinging are suffering now those of you who know dependence origination will know the middle links right which connect
which, shall we say, expresses how we create this suffering.
So remember there is this point of contact.
Then there's the discernment that what we're experiencing is pleasant or unpleasant, liking, disliking.
And then, of course, we choose to grasp at or desire rather, desire what's pleasant and push away what's unpleasant.
and and that's the reaction right but it's the next one where we upadana which means to cling to get hold of yeah now this upadana is manifest as in four different ways when i find a bit of paper yes it's first of all a clinging to the um to the pleasures of the senses
That's the sort of clinging.
And of course, if you are not being pleased, then your response is to get rid of it.
So there's always this duality of aversion and desire.
And the aversion, of course, splits into two.
You either get rid of it or run from it.
And then there's this holding onto views, opinions.
I'm right, everybody else is wrong.
That's also a sort of clinging.
Then there's this one about rules and regulations.
This is really going back to an understanding of the time when ritual was a way of appeasing the gods or demanding the gods to do something.
So if you think that, for instance, bowing to the Buddha, lighting candles and all that sort of stuff actually is going to liberate you, then you are definitely deluded.
So that's the rules and regulations.
But the one that I particularly...
reinforce when i'm talking about this is identity because that's where the root cause is the root cause is the sense of i and that's really where the suffering becomes existential right it becomes a position of me and that comes most obvious when death approaches us but also serious illness or indeed the death of somebody we love or the serious illness of somebody we love
impinges upon us it begins to question our identity because this identity this self this feeling of me has a feeling about it of permanence you know like even though we're quite happy to get rid of it when we fall asleep you know there's the presumption that next morning i'm going to wake up and say oh here i am again so uh that's the suffering so it's
pretty straightforward unsatisfactoriness, not being able to get fully satisfied with life.
It's always going to let us down a bit, even when we've got everything, you know, the right house, the right car, the right partner, the right children, et cetera, et cetera.
At some point, it just begins to disappear.
And that's the way it is.
Then there's the suffering, which is not getting what you want.
And then there's the suffering,
which is to do with this existential, this sense of self.
So this word dukkha, this word dukkha, which is very difficult to define, very difficult to translate, excuse me, because it has such a wide meaning.
And what the Buddha is really saying is that the whole of life, the whole of human life is unsatisfactory.
And I always liked the quote from Jesus on this when he said, the birds have their net holes, but the son of man has nowhere to rest his head.
So I think that's put it very, very poetically, very beautifully.
So then, of course, there's the there's the origin of suffering or the cause of suffering, and that is it is craving which brings renewal of becoming.
is accompanied by delight and lust and delights in this and that that is craving for sensual pleasures craving for becoming and craving for non-becoming this is called the origin of suffering uh it's translated it here as origin but uh i would probably prefer the word cause the basic cause of suffering so the word here that's being translated is tanha which uh
some authors, I think, probably are closer to the mark when you translate it as a thirst, a lack, a sense of lack.
That's another translation that some authors use.
And those get close to it.
Craving is a bit too strong, craving, although we do have cravings.
It's actually covering all desires, even from the simplest thing, like when you're watching TV and you feel a bit uncomfortable, there's a desire to move.
so if you watch all your intentions you'll see that they're all normally speaking desires to get rid of something you don't like or get something you do like and so we're constantly manipulating the world to make ourselves feel comfortable and uh it's accompanied you see with uh delight and it's got lust here but it's more like um
more like an indulgence, delight and indulgence.
So the question that we have to ask ourselves, when I want something, when I want something or someone from this position of trying to escape suffering, because that's what we're doing when we're often indulging things,
and also enjoying it, what is it that we really want?
Do we actually want the object we're desiring or the effect that the object has on us, right?
Have a guess, what do you think?
What is it we really want?
I mean, do we really want porridge or do we want what porridge does to us?
Toast, that's another one.
Yeah, I know I'm a bit obsessive about toast.
So it's trying to establish or trying to develop a certain mental state, isn't it?
A certain emotional feeling state.
And that's what this craving does or this thirst.
And it produces habits, produce habits.
And what we discover in...
on meditation, and even now with this lockdown, is that when you interrupt a habit, when you stop a habit, it suddenly becomes a choice.
Normally, we're running with habits.
You know, you get up, you do this, you do that.
You want a piece of toast.
See, I'm at it again.
And off you go.
But when you can't, when there's no bread, you see, or when the toast is broke, it's broken, isn't it?
The habit's broken, and it sort of comes back at you.
And now most times we would fight that and run out and get a toaster.
But it also gives us a choice, you see, a choice to bring about an end to that sort of compulsive behavior.
So if we look upon this lockdown, some of us are having to stay in, you know, in rooms, can't actually leave.
This is an opportunity really to see where these obsessive compulsive things are.
And of course it can be difficult.
It can be very difficult.
But that's the whole reason for practicing this vipassana, that you find a different relationship with it so that you allow the heart to express its turbulences, no matter how difficult that may be.
And what we discover, of course, is that that's the way it heals itself.
So that's the origin or the cause of suffering.
Sorry, I'm not finished yet.
There's also the craving for becoming.
So there's yourself, you see, always wanting to become.
And you'll notice how you're always ahead of yourself.
You're always thinking about what you're going to do in a minute or in an hour or this afternoon or when you go to work or when you don't go to work or when you retire.
Yeah.
What are you going to do, you see?
So the self never feels safe just being in the present moment.
It can't hold that position because it's unsafe.
It doesn't know what's going to happen next, for heaven's sake.
So this craving for constantly becoming.
And the other one is craving for non-becoming.
So that, of course, takes us to the dark side to put an end to this because of the suffering that we're having leading towards suicide, right?
that's the worst or if you're angry with somebody murdering them because they're stopping you getting happy but we've given that up remember because we take the five precepts yeah so that craving for becoming and craving for non-becoming that that digs deep again to this existential problem about who am i and that's the question who am i or what am i
then finally uh sorry and then the third one is cessation of suffering how how what how does that come to an end how does all this all this stuff come to an end so this is this is the regular formula it is the remainderless fading away and ceasing the giving up relinquishing letting go and rejecting of that same craving just this is the end of suffering the cessation of suffering
Now that sounds really simple, doesn't it?
Just to give up the craving, give up all these obsessive desires, this compulsive behaviour, and voila, you've made it.
But of course what we discovered is that that's no easy thing at all.
And that becomes very obvious when we go on retreat, just the difficulty of changing our habits completely.
The first three days, as you know, are all blood, sweat and tears.
And then it eases off a bit, but never a lot.
And it's always been a struggle.
So the practice is hard.
The Buddha doesn't pull punches on that, you know.
I'm sure you've heard me say, heard me quote from the scriptures there.
Somebody says to the Buddha, you know, this training is very hard.
And he says, well, he said, it is hard, but in the end, you're liberated, you achieve nibbana.
And the questioner says, yeah, so what?
And the Buddha says, well, at the end of it, you are happy and with it, contented.
Tutti sukha wahati, tutti.
That's the word for contentment, tutti.
Tutti frutti.
So that's this business of...
cessation uh and the final one is of course the eightfold path now the question is uh can it be argued is the buddha's most important teaching well uh if you can imagine when the buddha was you know had his awakening and it was said he spent a week thinking about especially dependence origination the psychology that he had discovered uh and then he began teaching uh
the first part of the scriptures which you'll see in some of you might know the nipata sutta which is was translated by uh venerable doc scientist was the um chief monk at the london buddhist vihara in 80 in the 80s and uh when i ordained he was my preceptor so uh although all my meditation teachers were burmese
my order was into one of the Sri Lankan orders.
And he's translated it.
It's a lovely translation, that, the Nipata Sutta.
And Bhikkhu Bodhi has done a great big, huge volume, which translates the commentary as well.
Now, the interesting thing about the Nipata Sutta is that it's pretty original.
And that always surprises me, really, because
you can see the original teaching wasn't so formalized.
He's answering individual questions.
And slowly, you know, the teaching becomes formalized.
And that's when you get these, you know, four of these, ten of those, nine of them, and so on and so forth.
And that formalization is the middle bit.
And then it becomes, towards the end, it becomes very sort of listy, like,
know to help you remember things and it and it begins uh you can see the big it begins to be a bit like the abhidhamma which was a later um development which takes about which takes away all that all the um what would you call it not humanity um when you read the scriptures you you do get the feeling of a person the buddha talking and people who are talking to him and as as the
teacher becomes more and more intellectualized that begins to disappear and it really does become lists so there's these three uh waves of development and it's interesting uh i think it's surprising shall i say that uh the oral tradition maintained those very early teachings they're there and then of course you get this uh more formalized the four noble truths
So when he has finally formalized it, these Four Noble Truths are the foundation of the whole teaching.
And you could say that if you come across any teaching, so-called Buddhism, which doesn't fit into the understanding of the Four Noble Truths, then it's not right.
It's not particularly right.
and uh each of these noble truths of course launch out into various other teachings and we'll we'll come to some of them very much in this particular discourse and so whenever you start whenever you start start talking about karma uh start talking about uh the body doesn't matter what where you start talking about what it what it is you start talking about you always end up uh
really investigating the whole of the dharma because it just leads from links one to another until you've you virtually covered it and you'll always come down to this root level about dukkha right that's if you were going to encapsulate one word which uh which expresses the buddha's understanding of the human condition that's the word dukkha um and if you if you
wanted to choose one word which um encapsulates the fundamental problem that we have it would be it would be atta self teaching around not self and if you were to choose one word which expresses the way out of it the actual practice to get out of it it would be sati awareness but but you'd have to put sama in front of it it's right awareness yeah it's a specific definition
So in other words, if you're thieving, you're fully aware, you know, but it's not going to get you liberated.
It might make you rich for a little while.
So that's the phone number.
I'm just looking at the time.
Oh, it's going on.
So I want to leave it there, and then tomorrow we'll have a look at the stages.
And the question is, are all the stages of the Eightfold Path equally important?
So we can have a look at that tomorrow.
Okay.
Very good.
So yesterday I forgot to take the refs and presets for those of you who would like to do it.
And then once I've done that, we can sit and as usual, towards the end, I'll do these contemplations.
Okay.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that I have not caused even greater confusion, and that by your devotion to practice you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.
Very good.
So I shall now do the chanting.
That's odd.
My computer says 25 minutes past eight, but my clock says half past eight.
i don't know okay we can begin oh
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Bodhansaranam Gacchami Damansaranam Gacchami Sangamsaranam Gacchami
Tuthi Ampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami Tuthi Ampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Tuthi Ampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Tatthi Ampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami
Tattyampi Dhamam Saranam Gacchami Tattyampi Sandam Saranam Gacchami Panati Pata Velamani Sthikapadam Samadhi Ami Adhinadana Velamani
Sikapadan Samadhi Ami Kame Sumi Cacera Vela Mani Sikapadan Samadhi Ami Musa Wada Vela Mani Sikapadan
so uh we can begin our sitting so make sure you
Comfortable, feeling comfortable.
And settling on the breath.
We can begin our sitting with these evening contemplations, which the Buddha says are there to make us more enthusiastic, to give us some real purpose as to why we're practicing.
So just...
repeating these phrases to ourselves this body is subject to disease this body is of a nature to fall ill this body has not gone beyond sickness
This body is subject to aging This body has not gone beyond aging This body is now in a process of aging This body is subject to death
This body has not gone beyond death This body will die There is the unborn, undying, uncreated, uncompounded
the unconditioned, true refuge, harbour and home, perfect peace and contentment.
Those who are mindful are in the presence, in the vicinity of Nibbana.